so you drive across country as we see in
the film with your best friend Anka hmm
and you guys have a lot of fun and then
you go through all sorts of world towns
and then you land in LA what was your
first stop and what was your impression
of LA well we got into Los Angeles it
was actually raining so that never
happens in Los Angeles and it was night
so it was really anticlimactic
but we we knew where we were going we
knew we were gonna be safe we were gonna
be with Holly we knew we were gonna be
in her guest house and you know with her
family so we were so exhausted when we
got into town as well that I think we
just had this great sense of relief and
contentment having made it and nobody
died and nobody got lost and contentment
at being with a really close friend and
her family kind of ready to rest and
then start the next segment of our task
so in the film your friend ina Cove
would turn to you every now and then and
ask are you happy so what about being in
a band makes you happy and is rock and
roll your
oh yeah that's that's probably safe to
say I do think that rock bands are a lot
like family they are not just about
making the music and I think people
relate to that too when they find a
favorite band I mean first the music
comes to you and you relate to a message
and then you want to know what do you
have in common with the person that
wrote this song and what's going on in
their life and it and it usually extends
to the entire band and usually there's a
closeness because vans don't make a lot
of money that exists between the members
and that's how they stay together and
that's how they do these the tough
things that is making music and being a
rock band it's more than than just the
commercial aspect there's a love between
the members and we certainly have that
and what makes you happy about making
music well no matter what I've done in
life I've always come back to music and
I think just because music affects
people so much it affects me so much
music is like a drug right you can be in
a really bad mood and then you can go
and put on a song and it will change
completely so you know anytime I've done
anything else in life and I have felt
maybe Hollow then a song will come on
and I'll be like I have to get back to
doing this so it just keeps pulling me
back in
you